[Music]
I saw some mid-1900s you're a kid
growing up in New York in the lower
class and you spend your childhood
seeing your parents struggling to make
ends meets they worry about making rent
they pinch pennies at every corner and
you think to yourself that there has to
be something better than this that I
never want to be poor again and then you
see these local Wise Guys mafia members
hanging around your neighborhood they
wear expensive suits Drive classy cars
get all the girls have all this money
and look successful people respect them
and they command fear basically they're
everything your parents aren't so you
start to idolize them and come to the
conclusion is a sucker dad he's a sucker
why would I want to go to school and
join the rat race just to end up like my
parents when I can join the most
powerful crime organization the world
has ever seen an organization so
powerful that at the height of the
Golden Years of the mob the five main
mafia families were equal to the size of
the top 10 U.S corporations at the time
they controlled Trucking the ports the
garbage business and a lot of the meat
produce and fish markets much of the
building trade
the Carpenters and electrical unions
they have judges on their payroll and
police in their pockets
the only problem is being not that the
most successful criminal organization in
the world their inner workings how to
join the mafia yield in secrecy so if
you want to become a successful mobster
you gotta learn the economics of the
mafia what's your favorite Mafia movie I
say Goodfellas is mine Godfather 2.
Godfather 2 really I love Bronx Tale
that was really Godfather too um like a
while ago oh we're going to have a
Godfather night then we'll watch one and
two three is garbage it's garbage
garbage it is Mafia movie Garbage three
Oregon is a business but obviously
they're not like many other businesses
see a typical business makes money by
providing value to the World by solving
customers problems Amazon provides value
through a huge selection fast shipping
among other things Google provides the
value of offering the entire human races
Collective knowledge at your fingertips
so these companies get paid money in
return for the perceived value they give
out to the world which makes their
owners feel free rich as it should the
problem is providing honest value is
kind of difficult for the most part you
have to work honestly you have to abide
by these silly laws and regulations this
is where the mafia has an advantage is
that the best money they're providing
value they make money by doing the exact
opposite through taking value
so you can think of the mod as sort of
an anti-business an anti-business that
isn't restricted by the plebeian lost
legitimate businesses are held to out of
all the different ways they make money
also known as rackets say protection
money and for trading labor unions or
just some good old-fashioned robbery
most of them revolve around taking value
from people by force take the classic
protection racket for example mob
members go door-to-door to Mom and Pop
shops and instead of solving a problem
they already have they create a problem
for them and offer the solution you have
to pay us a hundred dollars a week so we
can protect you from those no good
criminals who will break your windows
with analyze your property rob you and
maybe even hurt your family
if they accept great you're now bringing
in 400 per month in pure unadulterated
cash flow if they don't well then maybe
their Windows would be conveniently
shattered some pesky criminals this is
what's called a broken window fallacy
get a hundred brick and mortar is that
what that's texture and you what's the
the broken windows thing is that
something window fallacy I've never
heard of that expression before the
terminology the broken windows theory
states that visible signs of crime
anti-social behavior and civil disorder
create an urban environment that
encourages yeah that's crime and
disorder including serious crime no so
that had to do with like why in New York
City and those though and like LA are
going to complete [ __ ] because they
don't they don't police over any of the
Little crimes anymore they let whatever
slide so then if you if you're going
somewhere and there's graffiti all over
the trains and there's broken windows
everywhere you're more likely to be like
oh who gives a [ __ ] about this place
it's already a [ __ ] you can just you
know you can do whatever crime and
that's why New York back in the day they
um they painted their trains every day
to get rid of the graffiti and then
crime ultimately dropped in the New York
City Police Station and the train
stations because of that so I I think he
used that the wrong way actually no he
he said broken windows fallacy maybe you
have a nuanced difference from from
Theory let me see the broken window
fallacy just suggests that an event can
have unforeseen negative Ripple effects
if money is redirected to repairing
broken items rather than to new goods
and services okay so I guess he did
easier the theory suggests that a boost
to one part of the economy can cause
losses yeah so I think this is it this
is the they were using the broken
windows Theory to scare people that
things are going to go to hell if they
don't hire them to protect them yeah so
when those would be conveniently
shattered the next day by some pesky
criminals this is what's called a broken
window fallacy get a hundred brick and
mortar Source under your protection and
you have nearly half a million dollars
coming in every single year just from
one of your rackets without having to
provide any value when the mafia isn't
taking value from people their other
rackets operate kind of like would they
actually be like protecting you though
they did I I think they did provide some
value I meant businesses providing value
to customers by selling illegal stuff
since illegal goods are very profitable
think drugs prostitution illegal
gambling loan sharking and alcohol back
in the prohibition days whatever is
trending during the times with all this
racketeering money coming in the mafia
can't just outweigh spend this dirty
money because the IRS will wonder where
it's all coming from so they'll often
set up legitimate businesses to launder
that money and wipe off all that excess
blood away to make it look legitimate
they'll also get some legal income
coming in so it's a win-win situation
these could be stores legal casinos in
Las Vegas and Atlanta City and many
other fronts one thing the mob does have
in common with regular businesses is
money at the end of the day it's not
about honor respect loyalty God all that
other stuff you see in The Godfather
films to a Mafia Family the only God you
worship is the holy dollar and this is
where you come in uh no honor loyalty
respect secrecy those things are
absolutely and like completely tied to
the money without those things the money
can't exist you know or that you don't
rat your one and only duty is to help
make the family money more specifically
to make the head of the family the boss
or the Godfather more cash that is
literally all that matters and there are
two ways you can go about doing this
it's the best part when she wants to go
shopping and and he says how much how
much do you need and she said this much
delegate
[Music]
just like any other well-oiled
organization the military corporations
Etc the mob has a very well-defined
hierarchy and structure that you need to
climb this is why it's called organized
crime at the bottom of the pyramid are
Associates and this is where you'll
start out any criminal organization's
biggest bottleneck are people we need
great Innovative criminals to run our
Empire but how do we recruit them how do
we vet them how do we know that we can
trust them this is where Associates come
in they give yourself as an intern you
are nobody that isn't officially part of
the family yet but you're still working
on their official family members and
helping out in their Rockets shoveled
out my car after that snowstorm that
time I'm going to press on the totem
pole who had to work really hard to
prove themselves oh yeah oh they'd send
the [ __ ] to go and clean your clean
your car out for you yeah that's
hilarious Godfather wasn't coming out to
do it
so you you would just go in for a cup of
coffee and the gangsters just clean your
car that only happened once in this
really fabulous time that it was it was
so cold out it was freezing and all the
snow had turned to pretty much a block
of ice
it was so much work don't rat their code
of sun is to never reveal the secrets of
life to Outsiders or authorities this is
what made the mob appear Untouchable in
the eyes of the public and law
enforcement because they just couldn't
get anyone to talk or be an informant
which meant that if you were Prosecuting
the mob if you were investigating the
mob you really didn't have access to
anybody in the inside the breaking of
omerta is also what led to the downfall
of the mob which is a story for another
video another interesting rule to know
is that mod members never refer to
themselves as the mafia or the mob or
any other incriminating name like that
to keep out of the public eye into Thor
authorities they only ever refer to
themselves as Lacosta Nostra or our
thing in Italian in fact for the longest
time there are doubts as to whether or
not the mob even existed and people
claimed it was a mere conspiracy you've
had a number of successes haven't you
for example you managed to get the
justice department to drop the word
mafia entirely was that you're doing it
was the voice of all the Italian people
getting the justice department of the
United States to ban the use of the word
mafia
that's pretty good political power that
is pretty good political wow I never
knew this is how good they were staying
in the shadows around that time the
producer of The Godfather came to visit
Joe Colombo he sent for him and uh Joey
actually looked at the script of The
Godfather back then he took any
reference to the word mafia he pulled it
out of the script to become an associate
as a teenager is pretty simple and and
The Godfather they don't say Mafia have
you noticed did you notice that
I didn't notice it but it doesn't have
to have to pay attention mob loves
grooming kids from the streets when
they're young they'll start giving you
very small jobs here and there and if
they like you they'll start giving you
more and more responsibility to be an
associate as an adult is a little bit
trickier it's harder to trust you as a
grown adult and for the most part it's
better to demonstrate your value and how
you can make the money and let them
approach you take job with Stone's case
he was an undercover FBI agent posing as
Donnie Brasco a supposed jeweled leaf
and to become an associate he had to
hang out at the bars and restaurants the
mod members visited to develop
relationships for a whole six months
before he got to work for the family you
don't walk into a mafia place and say
Hey you know I'm Donnie Brasco jewel
thief I like to start doing business
what do you know yeah who do you know
yeah once you do become an associate
it's game time start making money for
Lem show them how ambitious you are but
not too ambitious to where you're
threatening people's egos another thing
to keep in mind is that the mod favors
Bloodlines you don't have to be fully
Italian to be an associate but for the
most most part you'll never be able to
become a main man if you're not fully
Italian or if you're connected to the
law and as you gain their trust as you
prove yourself as an earner or a killer
as you show them that you're an asset
that they need that's what made Henry
Hill so such an interesting character
because he wasn't full Italian oh and um
Good Fellas yeah well we'll see Irish or
something I remember I thought he was
Irish interesting
as an official member of La Costa Nostra
you're now free to move up the ranks
basically your duty is to help with the
rackets and find new innovative ways to
make money for the family here's how it
works when you were an associate you
work for soldiers and their Captain also
known as a couple which you can think of
as the manager who led that crew all the
different crews in the family take
orders from the next level in the chain
of command the underboss who's kind of
like the vice president that can take
over if the boss is taken down he's also
kind of like the family's chief of
operations that can oversee all the
day-to-day happenings of the family's
most lucrative rackets and then you have
the boss also known as the Don or The
Godfather he's like the CEO of the
family and has the final say on all
decisions and finally you have the
family's Consular area this is the
family's advisor and the boss's
right-hand man who's usually a trusted
friend and confidants who I'm gonna
continue referring to as the advisor
being that I'm definitely butchering
this the advisor is often seen as the
third in command of the family they're
also usually the meteors and disputes
and are the middlemen between the family
and other crime families and business
associates the reason why it's set up
like this is that not only does it help
with being organized but it also acts as
insulation the few at the top are
insulated from the petty day-to-day
crimes
and The Godfather tried very hard to
resist being part of the family and just
be a legitimate Citizen and he he got
sucked in he went he went to college he
went to he was in the Army he made that
nice you know white bread girl named K
and they fell in love and it was too
late and she got sucked in and she hated
it you're just talking about the movie
yeah but it's cool it's a cool story
it's a cool storyline all the crews run
the rackets of the family and as the
money is made thanks for the spoiler
chain of command whoever made the money
let's say it's an associate takes their
cut the associate passes the money up to
the soldiers and the capital of the crew
they get their cut and then it's past
that they be split between the underboss
I wonder what like the advisor so you
know
businesses You Know Your Role
the FBI you know rating rating people's
houses and is it not the government
being a political maker since they're
being pulled to partner Justice is also
so politicized now these people are
making all the rules controlling
everyone don't even follow them it's
kind of the same thing they were doing
they were pulling the strings behind the
curtain not following anything oh the
government had to hate them they were
original like I know like the original
people who looked behind the curtain and
was like [ __ ] this we are not letting
these people control us they saw right
through the government and all their
nonsense it's crazy
[Music]
[Music]